let's get the European reaction to
today's events from our Brussels bureau
chief max Hoffman and the reaction from
Moscow from correspondent our
correspondent there Emily Sherwin to
both of you good evening let me start
with you max will it be business as
usual in Brussels with a new coalition
government in Berlin it really depends
on the coalition Brent
but there's one party that many here in
Brussels and especially in France I
with.well suspicion the FDP the Liberals
if they are part of a government that
might cause some trouble there is the
story that we couldn't verify but with
true peared in French media about Mike
Ross saying so the French president
behind closed doors that if the FDP is
part of a German government then he's
done the thinking behind that is that
the FDP itself is very skeptical of some
of the ideas that it man around Michael
is trying to sell at this moment for
example a eurozone budget so we don't
think we'll have business as usual and
all the coalition partners have said
they want to change the business
business unclear exactly what what Agata
medical will do and what this business
will be in the future with the new
coalition we know that the EU has always
looked to Angela Merkel for strong
leadership can it still do that after
what happened today well she's still the
Chancellor and she's still the
Chancellor of Europe's most powerful
economy so there is built-in leadership
in a way here it really depends on what
she will be able to do within the
framework of a new coalition she might
not be able to follow my crawl as much
as she would have liked to because as
you know the German French engine of the
European Union which is extremely
important for anything to move on was
reborn with the election of McCraw and
Macross seems sort of like the rising
star in the European Union at the moment
while Mackel with this election more
seems to be like you know in the fall of
her political career but she still is
the most seasoned EU politician she has
the most experience but now she will
have to prove also to her EU partners
that she's able to to lead that new coal
that new government in Germany and
everybody will watch that very closely
here in Brussels yeah you're right me
she does remain the longest-serving
leader in Europe and in the Western
world Emily let me ask you about the
relationship to Russia is a weaker
miracle does that translate into a
stronger Vladimir Putin well if it is
the case that miracle is weaker than of
course that could be a distraction from
whatever is going on in Russia for her
so that could be a positive factor for
Vladimir Putin but of course I agree
with what max said she still is the
Chancellor and that's very much how it's
been perceived here the headlines here
in Russia have really read miracle wins
the election basically threw out the
board and so people here see it as you
know this is her fourth term but
Russia's leaders too are probably are
likely to be following the coalition
negotiations closely as well at the
moment it looks likely that she's going
to be working with the greens and the
Free Democrats and the Greens are very
critical of Russia they're very much Pro
sanctions whereas the Free Democrats the
FDP there was a small scandal recently
the leader of the FDP said that we
should be realistic about Crimea and
that the annexation of Crimea by Russia
should be seen as a quote permanent
provisional arrangement so he was
advocating realpolitik so they certainly
here in Russia will be watching closely
what happens with the coalition who
she's pairing up with but basically
people are focusing on Mirko I mean let
me just play devil's advocate here we we
know that the AFD is going to be the
major disrupter in German politics at
least for the next four years isn't that
exactly what Russia wants to see well
ahead of the election you know German
officials were saying that hacking could
be likely that that Russia is trying to
destabilize this election but then the
Interior Minister said that that there
wasn't any hacking so that could show
that actually Russia really does want a
stable
Germany Russia Russian German economic
relations are very important so I think
it's in Russia's interest to actually
have a stable Germany to have stability
here in the country but there is
excitement here about the AFD on state
TV I just I just saw that they had a
specific a correspondent that they
actually sent specifically to the AFD
headquarters they were talking about how
this will liven up the political life in
Germany and perhaps that excitement is
justified I mean this is the pro-russian
party that's going to be in the
parliament there against the sanctions
policy so that's likely to be seen as a
positive development here all right our
correspondents Emily Sherwin in Moscow
and max Hoffman in Brussels to both of
you thank you very much